finally we're going to get to
hierarchical clustering
which is another form of clustering but
different
and this works off a distance matrix
so
we'll use our same data yet and we'll
compute distance of x which computes a
100 by 100 pairwise distance matrix
and we make a call to h-clust
so h-cluster is the tool that we use for
doing hierarchical clustering
so by now you become pretty adept at r
if you want to find out more about h
clust you just go help hclest and you'll
get help online
um
if you
once you've computed the the foot if you
you can you know how to print it out
and you know if all else fails if
something else you'd like to find out
searching the web is a really good idea
these days if you search the web for
related queries tons of stuff comes up
and you can often find out all kinds of
interesting information
so here we ran
h clust with method equals complete
and we'll just plot the data
and it plots a dendrogram that shows the
clustering
so if you recall this is a bottom-up
clustering technique
where it continuously joins together
smaller clusters to make bigger clusters
until eventually you get to one big
cluster
now we know there's four natural
clusters in these data and from the
heights of the arms of the dendogram
it's evident that there are four big
clusters here and these will almost
certainly correspond to the original
divisions
in the data that we created
complete is is is how it decides
how close two clusters are and what
complete does is it uses the largest
pairwise distance between a point in one
cluster and a point in another cluster
um there's other methods we can use so
single linkage clustering it's called
it's the same call
except method equals single so instead
of looking at using the largest distance
it uses the smallest distance
and it gives you a rather different
looking picture and the four big groups
that we saw aren't as easily evident in
this one it seems to have found one two
three groups and then somewhere in here
is a division into the fourth group
so single linkage clustering tends to
to
to to find long strung out clusters
because it's just looking at the closest
point between
clusters and so
you might not get nice clumpy balls like
like we expect to see in this case
average is somewhere in between
and indeed the plot for average looks
somewhere in between but i think for
these data i think we probably prefer
the method equals complete
so we're going to
we're going to compare
with the with the actual clusters in the
data again
we'll use a function cut tree
and we'll cut it at level four
okay so that's the first thing we'll do
and and so that
cuts our original cluster tree
um let's just plot it let's get get its
plot up there again
here's the dendrogram so we've cut it at
level four so that means at the point
where there's four clusters so now we're
going to identify who's in each of these
clusters and for that we use the
function catri
and all cut tree does is you tell it the
level
that you want which is for you the
number of classes you want it's for and
it gives you back a vector of cluster
assignments so now we can use the table
function
to tabulate those assignments with the
the what we know to be the real
assignments which is given by a variable
which
and so you get this little table here
again the orders are arbitrary here
and so what you expect to see is
some big numbers with zeros elsewhere
right
so the big numbers are the 17 31 30 and
19
and then the small numbers are the mis
the mis identification so there were
three misidentification here
and we can also
do a tabulation and compare it with
k-means clustering
and with k means clustering
there were two two mis
two disagreements so both k-means and
hierarchical clustering
um didn't know the two assignments
and they agreed mostly but on two points
they disagreed
now you can
there's there's fancy ways that you can
plot hierarchical clustering trees
that
that actually tell you that color that
say the leafs according to
um the original cluster membership or
some other variables these tend to be
rather technical i i actually looked to
see how to do this by searching on the
web and even though i was able i was
able to do it it's probably too
technical to put in this demonstration
but if that's something you wanted to to
do i i urge you to have a look so people
have written functions for doing that
what we'll do is something a little
simpler the the plot command for for
dendrograms for for cluster trees has a
labels argument and we're going to label
it according to the original cluster
assignment
and
if you can see here
you'll see that all these guys down here
are fours there's twos
there's ones and and threes it's not
that clear but
if we had a bigger place to plot you'd
be able to see which which of the points
were were misassigned
so again
use the help
help to find out more about hierarchical
clustering
and and again if all else fails go and
search on the web
and once again this is a our markdown
document
in rstudio
so we can knit it and then we get a nice
html document which gives a summary of
of our results
and and with any figures we made in in
one nice document and
we got our figures this is something you
can share with some colleagues
or to show the analysis that you've done
for them
or for the demonstration
so there we go